this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant the
problem-solving website that teaches you
to think like an engineer last month
elon musk and drew baglino took to the
stage to share the latest developments
in tesla's battery technology with
investors and tech enthusiasts around
the world
if we were to boil down the theme of
this presentation down to a single
problem that tesla is attempting to
address
its supply chain logistics this battery
day focused little on increased energy
density
as the gains in this department become
increasingly difficult to come by
and tesla is now facing a larger problem
in the development of its batteries
in order to succeed in their mission to
accelerate the world's transition from
fossil fuel power
they need to scale their business
quickly in 2019
tesla sold about 365 000 vehicles
and over the last three years they've
averaged about 90
000 vehicles a quarter this can and
should
be deemed a huge success but in the
grand scheme of things
they are barely making a dent in the
total vehicle market
which in 2019 totaled 90
million vehicles despite their
reputation
tesla is a small fish in the automotive
world
and have a long way to go in even
matching the world's largest
automotive manufacturers like toyota and
volkswagen
who both sold nearly 11 million vehicles
each
in 2019 this battery day presentation
was a window into tesla's woes in this
quest to become
an automotive giant this slide in
particular
made tesla's ambition and challenge very
clear
in order to transition the world's total
vehicle market to battery electric
vehicles
they estimated that 100 times growth was
needed
taking the current production of
batteries at 0.1 terawatt hours
to 10 terawatt hours and similarly
they estimated that transitioning our
total energy consumption
would take another 10 terawatt hours of
battery production
every year a 1 600 time increase of
current production
for that sector we need to transition
away from fossil fuels
quickly but it's not going to be easy in
today's video i'm going to explain the
challenge
tesla and every other battery
manufacturer faces
in scaling and some of the improvements
they are working on
to reach their goals the battery supply
chain starts with mining
there are a number of different elements
we need to build a battery and without
them
the supply chain can't start there are a
range of battery chemistries that
different manufacturers use
for different applications and we will
briefly run over the most common
in order to get a basic shopping list of
ingredients together
let's first quickly run over how a tesla
battery works
and how we can get a bit creative to
ease the supply chain woes
a lithium-ion battery like all batteries
contains a positive electrode
the cathode and a negative electrode the
anode
separated by an electrolyte these
batteries are called
lithium-ion batteries because they power
devices by transporting
positively charged ions in the form of
lithium ions
between the anode and cathode creating
an electric potential between the two
sides of the battery
that forces electrons to travel through
the device it is powering
to equalize the electric potential
critically this process
is reversible for lithium-ion batteries
as the lithium ions are held loosely
sitting into spaces in the anode and
cathode's crystal structure
this is called intercalation so when the
opposite electric potential is applied
to the battery
through charging it will force lithium
ions to transport back across the
electrolyte bridge
and lodge themselves in the cathode once
again that's the core of what a battery
does
the anode and cathode materials provide
little storage bins for lithium ions to
park in between charged and uncharged
states
lithium is a constant feature of these
batteries
it's used because it's the third
lightest element and the lightest metal
allowing its ions to provide fantastic
energy-to-weight characteristics for any
battery
this is our first raw material that we
will need to source
to build our battery however lithium by
itself does not determine the energy
capacity of a battery
that is more dependent on the weight and
size of the storage bins
that the lithium ions park into for
example tesla's batteries primarily use
graphite as an anode material
graphite is a light material however
to store a single lithium ion the
graphite anode requires
six carbon atoms this gives a
theoretical
maximum battery capacity of 372 milliamp
hours per gram
but we can do better if we made our
anode from silicon
something tesla is actively researching
we need just a
single silicon atom to bind 4.4 lithium
ions
so even though a silicon atom is 2.3
times
heavier than carbon with the reduced
number of atoms needed
and the added storage space it gives us
11.3 times the energy capacity
with a theoretical maximum battery
capacity of 4200
milliamp hours per gram this means we
need less silicon
to make a battery with the same capacity
so improving our cell chemistry not only
makes our battery lighter
it means we use less material in our
batteries too
easing the strain on our supply chain
the problem is
those 4.4 lithium ions lodging
themselves
into the silicon crystal lattice causes
a volume expansion
of 400 percent when charging from empty
to full
this expansion creates stress within the
battery that damages the anode material
that will eventually destroy its battery
capacity over repeated cycles
making it a very difficult anode
material to work with
but tesla is working on methods of
fixing this and claim
they already have batteries on the road
with small percentages of silicon
in the anode so let's add these two
materials into our raw material list
now let's move on to the cathode here
different manufacturers opt for
different materials some optimize for
cost
like the manganese filled batteries of
the nissan leaf while sacrificing energy
density
while others optimize for energy density
like tesla
who primarily use a nickel cobalt
aluminium cathode called an
nca battery but they also use a
different chemistry for their stationary
power walls
where energy density isn't as important
here
they use a nickel cobalt manganese
cathode
tesla also uses lfp batteries supplied
by their chinese battery partner
catl in their chinese standard range
model 3s
whose cathodes are made from iron and
phosphate
if we plot the specific capacity and
average discharge potential of each
cathode material
we get a picture of each type's
performance with tesla's typical
batteries
the nca's being the clear winners and
lfp batteries
performing the worst it would be great
if all batteries could use this nca
chemistry
but as we will see some materials like
cobalt
do not have robust supply and come with
a host of geopolitical hurdles
which not only affects the supply of
batteries but their final cost
it's wise that tesla is already
diversifying the materials
on their shopping list and reducing
their reliance on
any one material which will help
mitigate any potential bottlenecks
if one material becomes hard to come by
this is a decent shopping list of raw
materials for potential batteries
graphite silicon lithium nickel
cobalt aluminium manganese iron and
phosphate
let's go shopping first i want to look
at the relative abundance of each of
these elements on earth
we are shopping in the earth's crust
after all these figures show the
percentage
each material makes of the earth's crust
silicon
dominates as the second most abundant
element on earth
making it even more attractive as an
anode material
aluminium and iron come next with
manganese and phosphorus
sitting mid-table with relatively high
abundance
which is why manganese iron and
phosphate are attractive for cheaper
batteries
however if we look at the bottom of this
list we see our three problematic
materials
nickel cobalt and lithium for the
purposes of this video
we are going to focus on these three
materials
this gives us a glimpse into the supply
problems battery manufacturers are
facing
but make no mistake this small
percentage of earth's crusts is still
more than enough to meet our demands and
relative abundance isn't necessarily a
sign of a robust supply chain
as we're finding some materials is more
difficult than others
there is not a huge amount of lithium in
a battery as elon put it
it's like the salt on a salad on average
there is about
70 grams of lithium per kilowatt hour
scaling that up to the average tesla 100
kilowatt hour battery contains about
7 kilograms of lithium a typical tesla
100 kilowatt hour battery
weighs about 600 kilograms so in total
the 7 kilograms makes up a small
fraction of the total materials used
however when scaling that up to 10
terawatt hours
which is 100 million 100 kilowatt hour
battery packs
things get out of hand quickly we would
need
0.7 billion kilograms or 0.7 million
metric tons
of lithium every year that's a lot of
lithium
even though it's just a tiny portion of
the battery
so how much are we currently producing
per year
this is the breakdown per nation
according to the u.s
geological survey with a grand total of
77
000 metric tons about 4.8 percent of
where it needs to be
it is however important to note that
worldwide reserves amount to 17 million
metric tons
and this is being held to prevent
oversaturating the market
and tanking the price if demand rises
sharply
this reserve can take up the slack with
enough there
to satisfy 24 years of tesla's 10
terawatt
hour dreams or even 12 years of their
greater
20 terawatt hour dream in the long term
there are many lithium deposits
scattered around the world
billions of tons of lithium is present
in our oceans but we have no
cost-effective way of separating it
at present instead we currently rely on
thousands of years of geological
processes
to concentrate seas into salt pans like
those perched atop
the andes in chile bolivia and argentina
here lithium-rich water lies beneath the
surface
which is pumped to the surface and
evaporated to collect the salts
there are also hard rock deposits in
places like australia
who are the current largest producer of
lithium we can also extract from clay
deposits
which musk touched on during battery day
where he told
shareholders that tesla had secured
rights to 10 000 acres of lithium clay
in nevada
but the process for extracting lithium
from clay
is unproven and these large reserves
have historically prevented any serious
investment into new mines
however it's clear tesla wants to
vertically integrate their supply chain
and lessen their dependence on external
suppliers who can hold back supplies
to keep prices higher sourcing materials
locally will also reduce the
environmental impact
and price of shipping it from overseas
even though there may be bumps along the
road
lithium for now isn't that high of a
concern
the same cannot be said for cobalt this
table
again from the u.s geological survey
shows the world's supply of cobalt
with one country providing a little over
70 percent of the world's total
production
in 2019 the democratic republic of the
congo
this has been a major controversy for
tech companies
who rely on cobalt for their batteries
in 2019
a landmark court case was launched in
washington dc
against apple google dell microsoft and
you guessed it
tesla for the horrible mining practices
in the drc
that their businesses fuel child labor
and dangerous mining practices are
commonplace in what the industry
disingenuously terms artisanal mining
tesla's primary workaround for this
issue has been to reduce the quantity of
cobalt in their batteries
this is obviously a complicated
geopolitical problem and i'm not
entirely sure
how tesla is supposed to intervene in
another country's human rights problems
and honestly
this is beyond my realm of knowledge so
i'm not going to weigh in
on a solution but it is a problem and
for this reason
cobalt at this time is the largest
supply chain bottleneck that worries
companies like tesla
a single supplier country with a history
of instability and human rights
violations
is a rusty link in the chain that is
just waiting to break
it's difficult to find an exact answer
for how much cobalt goes into a typical
tesla battery
but in their recent conflict mineral
report tesla claimed that their latest
generation
2160 battery has less cobalt than the
next generation
nickel manganese cobalt cathodes of
their competitors batteries
with an 811 ratio of nickel manganese
cobalt which would have about 6.6
kilograms of cobalt for a 77 kilowatt
hour battery
the best source i could find states that
the model 3 has about 4.5 kilograms of
cobalt
in its 75 kilowatt hour battery scaling
that up to 10 terawatt hours
would require 600 million kilograms or
600
000 metric tons a year this vastly
outstrips current output
of 140 000 metric tons but in this case
there is not a lot of room for
improvement in supply
with the drc sitting on the primary
source
and there are about seven million metric
tons of cobalt in reserve
but again half of this is held by the
drc
the only other major untapped cobalt
resources are under the ocean
with an estimated 120 million metric
tons
but i think we can all agree that
dredging the sea floor is not the
solution to climate change
we need to find an alternative to cobalt
tesla is working to replace cobalt
completely with nickel
which is a little over three times more
common in the earth's crust
than cobalt and has a far more robust
supply chain
being more evenly spread across the
continents however
nickel makes up most of the weight of
tesla's cathode and nickel is going to
be a bottleneck moving forward
tesla's batteries contain about 700
grams of nickel per kilowatt hour
so a 100 kilowatt hour battery would
have
70 kilograms of nickel significantly
more than
either of our previous materials scaling
this up to 10 terawatt hours
and we would need 7 billion kilograms or
7 million metric tons of nickel
and that's with today's chemistry if
tesla did replace cobalt completely
they would need even more today the
annual production
is 2.7 billion kilograms or 2.7 million
metric tons
with 89 million metric tons in reserve
but
it's a highly sought after material
being primarily used in the steel
industry
as a vital alloying metal used for
stainless steel
currently the electric battery market
only uses three percent of the annual
nickel supply
increasing to 10 terawatt hours of
production would swing that percentage
drastically and nickel mining would need
to ramp up quickly to keep up with the
demand
elon practically begged nickel producers
to sign an exclusive contract with them
for an environmentally friendly
extraction method
referencing the issues they are having
with their primary suppliers in
indonesia
whose mining practices are making people
question whether battery electric
vehicles are
actually good for the environment as
they are dumping the waste product of
the mining
into the deep sea while another russian
nickel producer
spilled 20 000 tons of diesel oil into a
river
in the arctic circle last year so
it's clear nickel and cobalt are our two
largest bottlenecks in our early stage
supply chain
but we are currently in the early days
of battery-powered vehicles
with few of these vehicles coming to the
end of their life each year
but that will soon change the number of
batteries available for recycling is
soon going to explode
at which point a more cyclical supply
chain through recycling will emerge with
mining becoming less critical to the
supply chain
today most lithium-ion batteries are not
recycled
in fact you likely have plenty of useful
lithium-ion batteries
in old electronics in your drawer at
home
sitting there because there is no
accessible way of recycling them
at present that trend cannot continue
for battery packs for vehicles
for the electric vehicle market to
survive and overcome these supply chain
issues
a cyclical supply chain needs to emerge
there are multiple startups vying to be
the world's first
large-scale lithium-ion battery recycler
one of them
redwood materials is headed by tesla's
former cto
and founding member but the supply chain
is much longer than this
these raw materials don't magically
assemble themselves into the form of a
battery
so tesla is working to remove
bottlenecks in manufacturing also
according to their slides with current
manufacturing techniques
tesla will need to build around 67
gigafactories to reach that 10 terawatt
hour milestone
with at least one trillion dollars in
investment required
building factories and raising the
capital to do it takes time
this too is a bottleneck in order to
reach their goals sooner
they need to increase the throughput of
their current factories
which means less factories are needed
while also increasing the capital they
are raising to build
new factories with this in mind let's
see how tesla is working to lessen the
effects of these manufacturing
bottlenecks
one of the most interesting design
innovations they displayed
during battery day was the tablets
battery design
which will dramatically increase their
factory's throughput
batteries have two current collectors a
copper foil for the anode and an
aluminium foil for the cathode
these can be rolled as part of the
battery jelly roll assembly
but the machine has to stop periodically
to weld something called a tab
to each collector these tabs then
connect to the positive
and negative terminals of the battery to
transport the electrons
out of the battery to the circuit having
to stop the rolling process to weld
these tabs
is kind of like forcing cars to stop at
a toll booth on a highway
it slows down the number of vehicles
passing through per minute
and causes a bottleneck in traffic this
new tablet's battery
has the tab rolled with the current
collectors and then folded in this
beautiful spiral origami fashion
at the top and bottom to connect to the
batteries terminals
this process removes this toll booth
effect in the factory that slows down
throughput
if this new battery manufacturing
technique speeds production up by just 2
that means they need 1.3 less factories
to achieve their goal
so it's clear tesla is prioritizing
rapid growth
they are entering a new stage of their
evolution as a company
where their scale is beginning to pose
new engineering challenges
however in the grand scheme of things
tesla's batteries can't
and won't solve this energy transition
problem alone
lithium-ion batteries are well suited to
the transport sector
but while tesla focused on that 20
terawatt hour mark in their presentation
i made my simple calculations based on
the transportation portion of their
goals
at 10 terawatt hours today lithium-ion
batteries are used in energy storage for
the grid
simply because they are currently the
best suited for the task at their price
point
but they do come with some drawbacks
they are limited in life cycles
aren't suited for longer term storage
and last year a large lithium-ion
battery firm
exploded in arizona causing manny to
reconsider lithium
as a safe option at this scale not to
mention there is little need for high
energy density batteries for the grid
we aren't moving them anywhere smaller
household power walls are one thing but
larger massive scale batteries like this
tesla battery farm in australia
are a waste of lithium and nickel those
materials are going to be needed for the
transportation sector
as countries around the world rush to
increase their renewable percentages
they are lacking behind on
critical energy storage facilities to
stabilize their grid
and looking towards lithium-ion
batteries in desperation
cheaper grid storage technologies are
needed now
and lithium-ion batteries simply aren't
the long-term answer
tesla thankfully doesn't have to take
the weight of global climate change on
its shoulders alone
we are in this fight together there is a
vast array of potentially cheaper
grid scale energy storage methods in
development
at the moment and i think in the next
five years or so
manny will hit a point where they can be
commercialized and compete
with lithium-ion batteries and cost i
recently spoke with professor donald
sottoway
a professor of materials chemistry in
mit
founder of ambry a liquid metal battery
company
and one of my academic heroes about his
views on the future of grid storage and
the potential of liquid metal batteries
segments of this interview will feature
in an upcoming video
on liquid metal batteries energy storage
for the grid is a young
and developing field that needs more
mines working on it
it's going to be one of the defining
technologies of this decade
that future generations will likely take
for granted but people like us
will look back with admiration for the
men and women that help
save our planet you could be one of
those people
if you choose to enter this field but
you're going to need a good
understanding of math
physics and computing to get started in
your career
brilliant is the perfect place to hone
your skills with easy to follow
curated courses that will take you from
knowing nothing
to having a well-rounded understanding
of the building blocks of an engineering
career
brilliant's thought-provoking math
science and computer science courses
help guide you to mastery by taking
complex concepts
and breaking them up into bite-sized
understandable chunks
you'll start by having fun with their
interactive explorations
and over time you'll be amazed at what
you can accomplish
if you are naturally curious want to
build your problem-solving skills
want to develop confidence in your
analytical abilities
or like me find fulfillment and
continual lifelong learning
then get brilliant premium to learn
something new every day
if you are looking for something else to
watch right now why not watch my
previous video about the astounding
floating harbours
which were floated across the english
channel on d-day
or real science's latest video detailing
the astounding new technique
that may allow scientists to create a
universal blood type
you